fifty years ago this summer Americans
saw monumental highs and lows on July 18
1969 senator Ted Kennedy drove his car
with a bridge on Chappaquiddick Island
in Massachusetts the crash killed his
passenger that's Mary Jo Kopechne II in
just two days later Americans went where
no human had ever gone before Apollo 11
astronaut Neil Armstrong stepped onto
the moon as the world watched in awe
then in August music fans and hippies
hippies were calling them descended on
hippies some were just music fans for
the three-day Woodstock Music Festival
author Ellen Hildebrand weaves these
events into her new novel summer of 69
it focuses on a well-to-do Massachusetts
family confronting its difficult past
and present Ellen good morning good
morning Tony being here thank you for
having this is your first historical
novel my first historical novel yeah
right in the in the authors note that
you weren't going for empirical truth
not truth as history tells it but
emotional truth what'd you mean by that
absolutely so I wanted to have the novel
be about my characters and not
necessarily about you know the issues
but I felt at the end like I was able to
weave them together so we have this
family that is involved in the moon
landing that is involved in
Chappaquiddick hippies they well you
know Woodstock plays a big part at the
end so I was able to weave all of the
elements that make 1969 so unique into
the novel but it seems personal because
that's a year you were born to that's
right so I yes that year always stand
out to you that one year I want I didn't
realise all that happened in the same
year either by the way not only did it
all happen in that year but it happened
the week I was born so I was born on
July 17 1969 and on the sixth an epic
week yes it was an epic week it was
Apollo 11 it was Chappaquiddick you have
a twin a house while you're rolling I
have a twin and I was gonna write the
story of my own birth but I had to move
it up a day so so you were so in a way
you were you were telling me your origin
story absolutely yeah absolutely my
story of Horton and one of the
characters involves a 19 year old
which also resonates with you who's
going off to war that's right it's a
character tiger character why does that
resonate that seems personal to so in
the very beginning of the book mind me
my main character Kate drops her son off
he's just been drafted into Vietnam and
I have a 19 year old son so I told Gayle
earlier it was easy to write that scene
because I could imagine and you have a
teenage son taking my son and dropping
him off knowing full well you may never
see him again you have a line in the
book where you're looking at everybody
there and you say somebody here their
son is not going to be coming at all
right it's indisputable that all the
parents dropping off someone's not
coming the last time that they and I
haven't been able to read that scene I
at any of my readings or signings it's
just too difficult you know what's also
interesting is that back then you hit on
racism you know it was kind of an
interesting twist to see the black
family that thought the white people
weren't good enough for their son I
thought that was interesting exactly
there's a me-too movement exactly and
there also is how women are treated you
tied all of that together - absolutely
so the you know the issues of 1969 are
still present today so the book feels
really relevant even though it's at 50
years ago do you find writing an
historical novel more challenging I did
I did but it was so interesting because
I my main source of research was asking
people their memories so I went to
people who were alive who were teenagers
who were young adults in 1969 that would
be fascinating and it was that was the
greatest amount of research I loved it
every time you come Ellen I'm always
reminded when I first met you five years
ago she was here guys at the table the
day before you were having a double
mastectomy yes and I remember saying to
how could you be here on the day before
and you said well what else would I do
right and I said well I would be home
looking at my boobs make one more look
at them yes or I'd be in the fetal
position you said no I've already done
that nope I'm just gonna go through this
day like it's a normal day I don't
marvel that so five years later I'm
thinking you're looking pretty good how
you feeling as you Gail well I feel I
feel healthier I feel happier and I feel
wiser do you yeah absolutely well I
think I got a lot of gratitude and I was
able to really focus on the things that
matter only the things that matter
that's so great very the Somerby tree
still yours it appears
all right Alan Hildebrand thank you very
much for being with this summer of 69 is
on sale now and you can read the first
chapter by going to cBS This Morning
Calm